and I want to start with you because we
met you or at least I met you when I
think you were about 13 you were fresh
and the to all the boys universe and my
name thanks for asking is Catherine song
cubby Kitty to my friends you can call
me Catherine now you're almost at your
20th birthday happy early birthday
to be with a character this long what
was it like going from the curious
little sister to now the more grown-up
romantic lead totally it was very
interesting to have that experience of
coming back to a character that I have
so much love for but it's also them in a
very new environment in a new time of
their life so I've been comparing it to
like coming back to an old friend that
you know really well but haven't seen
for many years because you have to
relearn them and and see what what
they've been going through last years
like she's grown so much and there's
Parts about her that I kind of have to
introduce myself to but also there's so
many things that are familiar and that
Spirit of kitty that we know from the
movies still carries through in the show
and you still kind of feel the same to
all the boys magic but in a new
established kind of world so it was fun
to create that balance and to figure out
what that meant let's make it packed no
more secrets between the Covey girls I'm
so proud of everything that they're
doing I've been talking to them as like
an actor and as a friend who's you know
turning to them for support in this
experience because I've never really
been the lead and not of something like
this for sure and to have have someone
to turn to when you need it really makes
a big difference
I'm ready to start experiencing new
things I want my own adventure I love
reading YouTube comments and on the
trailer for EXO Kitty the most like
thumbs up comment was the moment where
you jump on you know yeah that's the
most thumbs up comments people are like
I can't believe this is the same Kitty
are you excited to give your fans a more
grown-up version of this character I
think yeah it's so fun to get to grow
with the character and I think viewers
feel that way but I I definitely feel
that way because I've kind of grew up
like holding hands with Kitty like we
kind of got to do it together which is
really special but she's 17 now so it's
very different when she was like 12 13
11. in the movies so that that time of
life is also kind of her where Lara Jean
was like it's it's her turn there's
there's a line in one of our scenes
where I'm like I'm turning into LJ yeah
it's Kitty realizing like oh those
things I used to like make fun of you
for like you should not understand
because I was a kid like now I get it
you know it's my turn so definitely it's
that Dynamic of her love life and when
things things are her own steaks things
are a little different she is a woman
coming into her own it is so fun to go
on this journey and I've also loved
meeting Q what a great character what a
great job you do thank you you know this
is a big deal being in this to all the
boys Universe it's been known to launch
some real big stars and some real big
heartthrobs so I'm curious you know how
do you prepare for the success that
comes with a role like this you know
I've been doing this my whole life and
to this day I still get nervous for
things like this so there's not really
much I prepare for I just make sure I
know my lines and I'm like ready to do
the job I don't like to think about like
the aftermath of things because I feel
like that comes with a lot of anxiety
yeah good or bad
um hopefully good hopefully good yeah of
course yeah but honestly I'm I'm just I
love the work I love the art that's why
I do what I do I would put money on the
fact that this was a real fun shoot
those scenes I don't know which one was
the most fun the parties the dorm scenes
being into school what was it like when
the cameras weren't rolling how did you
guys really form that Bond I mean it was
really easy it was immediate too like so
quick I like I said I've been doing this
my whole life and I've never really like
experienced such a cast that is so
willing to work and like everyone left
their egos at home and just came had the
same like common goal we all had so much
love for each other too and so much
support which I feel like that that
means so much and makes such a
difference when you're working together
and you're in this other like for us
especially we like moved on the other
side of the world to from experience
like we gotta go to International School
ourselves
new friends and new challenges and new
experiences learning new things totally
like majorly and to have each other's
support in that and to have a safe space
within our group was like made a hugest
difference for sure any karaoke nights
so much I was gonna say specifically
literally karaoke and fried chicken I
think
that was a great combo right there okay
go to karaoke songs Baby by Justin
Bieber that was my solo one but we did a
lot of Disney we did a lot of Duets
um
classic classic that was on repeat
I say for me We Belong Together by
Mariah Carey I feel like that's such a
great ballad you want to give us a
little oh God
[Music]